Гуркало  — ця іграшка
існує ще з первісних часів.
Вона колись використовувалась
як шумовий ритуальний інструмент.
Коли етнографи почали
досліджувати Австралію та Океанію,
то вони знайшли
такі іграшки у папуасів.
Вони їх використовували
під час різних релігійних обрядів.
Наприклад, таку іграшку використовували
тільки чоловіки у певні дні,
а жінкам і дітям навіть не можна було
бачити їх і торкатися до них.
Давно вже таке значення іграшки забулося,
але в Україні ще в 20 столітті
діти бавились ними.
Ми знаходимось в селі Княгининок.
У нас тут новостворений музей історії села.
Тут в нас представлені старовинні
фотографії, старовинні іграшки
та колекція іграшок, які я відтворив
за допомогою етнографічної літератури.
Найбільше діти люблять
різні рухомі іграшки.
Цю іграшку з кулькою ми
називаємо «попадалка».
Інший варіант цієї іграшки —
це чашка з кулькою.
Один з французьких королів,
здається Людовик XIV,
навіть під час офіційних прийомів
бавився такою іграшкою.
Тобто це міжнародна іграшка,
характерна для різних народів Європи.
Українці кажуть,
що це наша давня іграшка.
Французи можуть казати:
«Це наша іграшка».
Європейська назва —  «більбоке» .
Один із найцікавіших експонатів —
ось такий возик.
Я дуже довго полював за таким возиком.
Разом з возиком мені вдалося придбати
фотографії дівчинки, яка в цьому возику каталася.
Це такий традиційний возик,
який був в Україні
в ХІХ та першій половині ХХ століття поширений.
Такі возики дуже характерні
взагалі для всієї Європи.
Вони вже давно не використовуються.
Але, якщо ви знаєте, в квіткових магазинах
стоять такі маленькі подібні возики, чи їх ставлять в садках,
ставлять у них квіти, тобто вони
виступають як деталь інтер'єру.
Я багато років займаюсь популяризацією
народних ремесел, зокрема виготовленням писанки.
Мені стало цікаво, що таке можна придумати,
що буде актуальним цілий рік,
тому що писанка — це більш сезонно.
Іграшка цікава дітям і влітку, і взимку.
І ось, я почав гортати етнографічну літературу,
десь шукати колекційні зразки,
і почав сам відтворювати їх.
З самого початку,
коли я почав займатись народною іграшкою,
я навіть не ставив за мету
зробити 10 чи 20 іграшок.
Мені було цікаво відтворити
по одному примірнику кожної іграшки
і просто демонструвати дітям,
якими були іграшки в давнину
і таким чином привертати їхню увагу
до народної культури.
А потім я зрозумів, що люди
потребують цих іграшок.
В першу чергу, я почав виготовляти
для своїх друзів, знайомих, похресників.
Потім навіть почав продавати
іграшки на ярмарках.
І тоді ми зрозуміли,
що потрібно це все об'єднати.
Ми створили проект «Українська Іграшка»,
створили спільноту на Facebook,
виставляємо фотографії з наших майстер-класів,
інформацію про різні іграшки,
описуємо літературу, з якою ми працюємо для того,
щоб ті хто цікавиться іграшкою,
могли відкрити, наприклад,
Грушевського і почитати з першоджерела
від тих етнографів, які описали цю іграшку
ще на початку 20-ого століття.
Також,  ми представляли українську
іграшку за кордоном.
Ми були в Польщі, Туреччині минулого року.
При виготовленні іграшок,
якщо не використовувати шаблонів,
а точити «на око»,
то іграшки виходять цікавішими,
бо наприклад іграшки, які виготовляють в Китаї,
вони всі однакові, виготовлені за копією,
тобто вони не мають своєї індивідуальності.
Коли брати дещо різні заготовки,
то іграшка виходить ніби одна й та ж,
але одна трішки довша, більші чи менші ручки,
від цього іграшка стає цікавішою.
Ну ось, качалочка готова.
Для того щоб розбиратися в етнографії,
зараз можна навіть не їздити по селах,
можна просто слідкувати за OLX.
Старі люди помирають,
діти це виставляють на продаж.
І можна зрозуміти, чи річ звичайна, чи унікальна
по тому, скільки є позицій.
Тобто, якщо шукаєш 5 років,
знаходиш лише одну, то це річ унікальна.
Якщо ткацьких станків в кожній області є десятки позицій,
це означає, що це є досить поширена річ.
Старовинних речей виставляють багато,
але таких унікальних і цікавих речей є досить мало.
Треба постійно слідкувати.
Навіть знати, як правильно вводити у пошук тому,
що люди самі можуть не знати, що це за річ,
і називати це якимись ефемерними словами,
до прикладу, старовинний предмет.
Ти можеш вводити у пошук «токарний станок»,
а він продається під назвою «старовинний предмет».
Потрібне терпіння і час.
Однак, це все одно простіше,
ніж їздити по селах і шукати по людях.
В нас є машина і возик,
вони виготовлені у 1930-их роках на Буковині.
Ці дві іграшки зробив тато для своїх дітей.
Якщо хтось каже,
що автомобіль — це сучасна іграшка,
то скоро буде вже 100 років,
як в Україні діти бавилися авто.
Що цікаво, якщо глянути знизу дно машини дуже протерте.
Це означає,
що колеса мінялися неодноразово.
Навіть, тут є сліди від цвяхів, тобто колеса відвалювалися,
тато чи дідусь прибивав їх знову, і діти далі грались.
Іграшка — це такий продукт,
що може представляти Україну.
Тому що в нас край лісів. Хоч може це звучить
трохи помпезно: «край лісів»,
але фактично наша деревина вивозиться на Захід,
а з Заходу до нас приходить мода
на щось таке шаблонне, нецікаве,
і ми просто копіюємо те,
що є на Заході.
Форма наших виробів, столярки
або іграшки вже втрачається
і дуже шкода,
коли автентичне не підтримують.
Цей жарт — про важке дитинство
та дерев'яні іграшки
виник у радянські часи,
коли з'явилася пластмаса,
яка давала можливість зробити
та відтворити мультиплікаційних героїв,
тобто вже дерево було немодним.
Хоча, багато старших людей підходять
і з теплотою згадують післявоєнні роки,
коли їм тато чи дідусь виготовляли
ті чи інші іграшки.
Кажуть, що це вже не збереглося.
В людей аж сльози в очах,  коли це бачать,
бо вони згадують, що такими іграшками бавились.
Дерев'яна іграшка є досить модною.
Ця мода йде з Європи, з Америки.
Там дерев'яні іграшки завжди
були на почесному місці.
Вони завжди там дорожчі і цінуються більше,
ніж пластмасові іграшки.
Все одно, дерев'яній іграшці доводиться
конкурувати із пластмасовими.
І весь час же пластмасові іграшки з'являються нові,
з якимось новими функціями, тобто буває дуже важко.
Але скільки б пластмасові іграшки не з'являлися,
все одно, дерев'яна іграшка
лишається незмінною для багатьох.
Надіємося, що в Україні також
вона буде цінуватися
і пластмаса не зможе витіснити
дерев'яну іграшку з ігор наших діток.